IT IS NOW TIME TO PLAY
X MARKS THE ART SO TO HELP
ME INTRODUCE THIS IS ONE OF
THE STARS OF "X-MEN:DAYS OF
FUTURE PAST" OPENING FRIDAY,
ICEMAN HIMSELF SHAWN ASHMORE
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> HELLO.
>> HOW ARE YOU, MAN.
>> WELCOME, LET US SHARE THE
PODIUM.
>> THANK YOU, GUYS.
VERY NICE, VERY NICE.
>> YES, I KNOW.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME,
CHRIS, LISTEN, X-MEN FANS
ARE PASSIONATE AND NOWHERE
ARE THEY MORE PASSIONATE
THAN DEVIANT ART.COM SO ONE
OF MY FAVORITES IS THIS
PAPARAZZI PHOTO OF ME. I'M JUST
BROING OUT, EATING ICE CREAM.
>> THERE ARE YOU, LOOK AT
THAT. JUST HAGING OUT.
>> NOW, THIS IS A DRAWING,
RIGHT, SHAWN.
>> HUH?
>> ARE YOU-- SORRY.
>> I WAS JUST ATTRACTED BY
THE NIPPLE DETAIL, IT'S NICE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> IT IS.
ISN'T IT?
>> IT'S PRETTY AMAZING.
ALL RIGHT, ANYWAY.
>> THIS ONE IS JUST SLOWLY
STARTING TO FREEZE OVER.
>> IT'S NICE DETAIL, I
THINK.
>> IT REALLY CAPTURED ME WELL.
>> THERE'S ANOTHER FAVORITE
PICTURE THAT A FAN TOOK OF ME
BUT I DON'T WANT YOU TO JUDGE
ME, IT WAS --
>> OH, SURE.
>> LISTEN, IT WAS COLD, IT
WAS COLD, THERE WAS A LITTLE
BIT OF SHRINKAGE.
>> A LITTLE, DO MEAN YOU
HOLDING YOUR TINY SELF IN YOUR
HAND.
>> THIS IS SHRINKAGE.
I SAID THERE WAS SHRINKAGE,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO TELL YOU.
I HAVE A QUESTION, IF I GOT A
BLACK EYE COULD ICEMAN
TEABAG ME TO MAKE THE
SWELLING GO DOWN.
>> FOR YOU, I WOULD DO THAT.
>> OKAY, GOOD.
>> SHALL WE INTRODUCE THE
GAME.
>> OK, COMEDIANS CHRIS IS GOING
SHOW YOU PICTURES FROM
DEVIANT ART THAT ALL SEEMS A
LITTLE SUPERHEROISH.
SO I WANT YOU TO GIVE THE THING
IN THE PICTUREA SUOERHERO NAME
>> GREAT, SHAWN ASHMORE,
EVERYONE. GO SEE X-MEN.
>> ALL RIGHT, SO LIKE SHAWN
SAID, I'D LIKE YOU TO GIVE EACH
OF THESE WORKS OF ART A
SUPERHERO NAME.
HOW ABOUT THIS MUSCULAR
MANICORN.
>> DENISE.
>> POINTS, POINTS NEXT ONE.
>> THIS WOMAN WITH A GIANT
BLUNT THAT'S LARGE AND IN CHARGE
>> LOOK WHO FINALLY CAME TO
LIFE IN THIS GAME.
YES, DOUG BENSON.
>> MRS. DOUG BENSON.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> POINTS.
>> ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE. NEXT
ONE.
>> LOOK AT THIS COUCH POTATO.
>> YEAH, GREG.
>> NICE PERSONALITY WOMAN.
>> POINTS. POINTS.
>> WONDER WHERE MY VAGINA IS
WOMAN.
(APPLAUSE)
POINTS. LAST ONE.
>> THIS GINGERHORSE. THIS
GINGERHORSE.
>> OH MY.
>> YES, DOUG.
>> HALF-ASSED.
>> OH, NICE, YEAH, POINTS.
>> ALLY McBESTIALITY.
>> GOOD, POINTS.